cuz gum the opposite house gum Rasmus
beer to pack welcome to some our alkalis
rift I said I was gonna play more
because it makes me nauseous I found
some pretty cool game so we're gonna do
it anyway the things I do for your
breath okay this game is cold [ __ ] no
way
alright so this is pretty cool I'm on a
boat I have a stick in my crotch I'm
ready to party just like real life baby
so I guess I'm supposed to go down there
alright I'm not even underneath yet okay
well - she's oh I killed Wally our
friends oh no he's devastated let me
kill all of them just because they're
devastated don't show human emotion
[ __ ] alright so do I have lucky' oh
that's [ __ ] weird man
Jesus Christ is that a male one of you
why why don't you oh it's the oh it's
that alright I got it alright I better
go out oh boy that sure was fun let's go
here out boat what are you doing don't
[ __ ] with me but boat how what are you
doing about I thought you were fro all
right well let's go deeper I don't like
this at all
that is so I have a flashlight okay
doesn't really help it does help a
little bit oh god it's so scary
Oh gives me the goose pimps got goose
nips all over my body man seriously
under water fishes freak me the [ __ ] out
of me never said it's gonna be a giant
octopus I am no peeing out of here man I
[ __ ] hate active places I was like
boxes and [ __ ] down here
he's so kawaii let me get you my gum on
again oh [ __ ]
I'd do anything with you oh god what is
that oh god I'm getting a text
huh huh oh they're cray cray cray cray
oh oh oh what do i do shoot it
oh god oh god it's coming right for me
oh [ __ ]
what sure do ha ha oh god I'm so deep
down where the [ __ ] are they I got the
keuken I know karate
watch out sharks you don't [ __ ] with me
I'm a full-blown black belt karate
master champion okay I didn't actually
graduate but you don't know that I'm a
navy it's a miracle no I'm dead yeah I'm
[ __ ] dead ha ha ha ha
I'm gonna kill one of the Sharks next
they're going down after you after you
Steven Steven don't judge Oh God [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you [ __ ] haha is that my blood
Oh lovely hi oh god is eating my face
that's awesome wow this is the best game
ever
alright here we are again oh there's a
ton of fishes here
oh [ __ ] oh I got you I tagged that [ __ ]
in the ass
oh god its piss now isn't he woah help
these chicks everywhere I'll gather
their breakdancing oh [ __ ] they're not
breakdancing they're running for the
life okay
okay why is my head old till 10 what I
say
like this boat I don't bounce out but I
need you right now
[ __ ] well you know what would they say
if you can't beat them join them
I'm a shark hey I'm a shark mmm ah [ __ ]
I miss sorry sorry I'm still a shark
there's a boat down here Oh God
oh oh I'm dead I'm dead
oh hi fantastic best game ever ten out
of ten perfect okay well that was
interesting we got some more under what
we're going with it underwater theme
bird today so let's check out the next
game the next game is a regular day as a
dolphin so it's pretty much a Japanese
simulator got my xbox got my dolphin ass
and I'm ready to play classroom aquatic
how to play filling the answer throw
eraser okay avoid teacher and student
gates okay
look at other students paper to get
answers fantastic throw eraser at people
and things to cause distractions what
the [ __ ]
ace the test pop quiz oh god I hate Pat
Chris Jessica this guy you got man hey
hey outside what what a shed attempt or
guy Jimmy
don't worry so long as you studied
shouldn't be hard
[ __ ] it's just ten question you'll be
able to finish in five minutes and I
don't want to see anyone taking their
eyes [ __ ]
alright everyone you may begin send him
a [ __ ] goddamn it Eddie
steady it out hey Stephen yeah what is
this
Egyptians new kingdom was constructed
for what [ __ ] hey get off all
right
they're on the same quest mmm what's the
answer all right the answer is eight all
right got it I'll have to do is be a
dolphin and look at all the other people
can't help you son of a [ __ ] if you
[ __ ] me over again nothing nothing
nothing just stretching
you know dolphins need a stretch to in
this foundation right okay what's the
answer
all right she put eight you might not be
wrong Jess the guy you study horse Simon
study dolphin how do I throw in the
racing huh [ __ ] back that's what you
get you [ __ ]
you get one too for looking at me that's
right
you get one because I don't watch she's
yelling at them now that's fantastic the
slope will sir kay's is referred to as
[ __ ] was on that one move your [ __ ]
hands alright great fantastic see best
game ever
alright the temperature of boone sun
burning flame rangers too bad [ __ ] come
on speed up no she saw me I'm sorry oh
sorry oh it's not a new perfume wow you
smell like seaweed the average gas
station period for a sperm whale is what
the [ __ ] there's this
oh god I'm running out of time alright
you know what fine eight out of ten
how's it fail that's like awesome the
[ __ ] dolphin school is really strict I
thought I did really well oh well I
guess I'll go with the whales and the
stupid class from now oh boy oh boy all
the dreams are coming true with this
game's oh my god so good best game ever
I would rent it i rated ten dolphins out
of - whales yep it's really good Jesus
Christ that's creepy okay it looks a
little sketchy but hey let's give it a
try
I figure we finish off with a horror
game I'll use my big beauty Gainey with
Spurs part 1 look around for tips okay
full game will come out if positive
feedback what what if negative feedback
all right well it looks cool oh they got
mushroom oh okay
wow this place is great
I have everything I could ever want in
this place I'm gonna I'm gonna live here
this is my home
whoa not going down there that's for
[ __ ] sure all right I better duck all
right got it easiest game ever what's
that now positive for you sorry up great
difficulty a gay member okay I like a
fog makes it cool smite my baby
should we go down there maybe no we
should we jab blood oh god that is
freaky man
girl where are you going girl girl where
are you going girl good girl girl hi oh
god you're ugly that is freaky as [ __ ] I
want to make out but at the same time
Oh his intestines are still there I want
it I want it I wanted to weird things
with your body man I do not explain it
hello oh you [ __ ] yes [ __ ] it abou
that is great for you yeah I tell you
why did you tell me about the mean girl
alright Jesus I guess we're going here
then I watch how's life don't care
great times what is this you better not
come alive or some weird [ __ ]
yeah I'm signing on you [ __ ] what are
you gonna do about it oh god oh god he's
coming alive we better get out of here
that's right give me hugs oh no dad when
I say hug that don't mean tentative
don't don't actually hug me okay God
thought that was obvious
Jesus Christ
behind me oh there's nothing oh god I'm
going now I'm going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
Jesus this is freaky man okay stop with
the noises I'm a man what do you want
from me Mamma Mia [ __ ] who keeps
breaking all the bottles okay not cool
oh god oh oh oh god that it's not funny
that is so not funny oh man I want to
take the risk
oh okay I don't jump-scare me like that
ah let me get the key I get the key yay
what you gonna do about my new shoes
open I am are there sayonara [ __ ]
sigh a [ __ ] arrow on my Laura Barra I
[ __ ] stretched my arm from that jump
scary oh god stop what what it what is
it now I'm a tea bags oh my what a mask
oh god oh my god Oishi hahaha that was a
very short demo bigger with keys to find
okay uh it's it's fun to [ __ ] around
with alkalis I'm glad I'm glad it's
short because if I play long it gives me
motion sickness so that's it for me
today hope you enjoyed watching bras
leave a like if you did let me know
which one was your favorite hits the
Skycam robe today and I'll see your
breaths and next episode thanks for
watching
stay awesome